ok ça va quoi rencontre au sommet comme
promis stéphane auzias ce soir est ami
ami avec la princesse de la pop aux 37
millions d'albums en toute simplicité
britney spears dit tout et stéphane à
l'occasion de la sortie de son troisième
album
[Musique]
tout d'abord merci pour cette interview
je suis un grand fan atteint bien mon
t-shirt
j'adore ton tee shirt et des incroyables
j'adore les pires qui brille j'aime tout
ce qui s'attirent soa
oui tu es en train de voir ton nouveau
clip audio
c'est une nouvelle britney puis à thé
sexy pas vraiment j'ai toujours eu sur
moi avec ce type de musique je le fais
sortir encore plus
ça fait super star on c'est génial
j'adore être connu ses toiles les
inconvénients étaient connus soit passé
quoi les trucs sont a bien tenté koné
journaux à scandales a fool probablement
est très éloigné de ma famille mais à
part ça c'est très cool je ne m'en
plains pas est-ce que tu pensé un jour
one day devenir aussi célèbre jamais
jamais non non c'est quoi la première
chose que tu sais quand tu te réveilles
le matin la première chose que je fais
le matin c'est de me brosser les dents
parce que mon haleine senti terriblement
est la dernière chose que tu fais quand
tu vas au lit la dernière chose que je
fais me brosser d'état kenwood faux la
dernière question mais c'est ce que tu
as un message pour ses fans français je
voudrais dire à tous mes fans français
vous manqués et merci beaucoup pour tout
votre amour et votre soutien et je vais
venir bientôt l'année prochaine alors
attendez moi
[Musique]